these women are wearing not much more
than underwear and wings declaring we're
all angels they're fighting back against
the iconic brand Victoria's Secret
insisting women of all body shapes and
sizes should be celebrated not shunned
Robyn Lawley is a size 16 model who
started a petition boycotting the brand
altogether I just have to look at the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show and I
used to hate my body and I have a
daughter and she's going to be my body
type I'm broad I'm tall I can't be that
size physically I cannot be that size
that they're warning that's why our
bodies are beautiful in all their
diversity the Victoria's Secret Show is
watched by millions of people and sees
the world's top models take to the
catwalk all are a size 8 or smaller I
want to see diversity I think in this
day and age we need diversity and
there's no reason why we shouldn't have
women of all shapes and sizes and
abilities on the catwalk still cater for
someone like me I don't mind what they
yeah well they look like on the catwalk
doesn't change my opinion of them it
does portray it such a unattainable goal
but if they had all different sizes of
women and different race and everything
it just means much more like welcoming
to everyone Tess holiday recently graced
the cover of Cosmo and there were those
who warned of glamourizing obesity so
getting a balance right is challenging
we're at a juncture right now where
we're seeing a lot of extremes in terms
of bodies and we need to be able to come
to a place where we can see
middle grounds around our body and how
we're represented but events like this
clearly show how far the industry has
come when I cited modern there wasn't
any models out there like me it's very
very tough very challenging but I think
that gave me even more Drive and passion
to be the change I wanted to see in the
industry
so a boycott may not clip the wings of
Victoria's Secret as it will continue
the conversation around body image and
its importance through spotter Sky News